me
今日は社長です今ゲー今回こそもう俺一人でいない星
100個食べると思います投げているずっと大きいから行くよく見ると投げてる雑感
大きい気もするんですけども
まあそれではやはりあの僕最近結構多いとかあの動画が威力やってるんで犬を着たが
比較的に大きくなっていると思いますそしてお肉以外のものばっかり食べてるんで
米好きなので多分
これぐらいのいなりずしだったらパッと食べると思いますさらにくら寿司で買ってき
ます上同じ余裕ですよまってこれねえずしてごらんキロカロリー分だと2巻1されたん
ですよ
多分これひと皿分のアレなんでセク42かける午前7100キロカロリーぐらいだと
思います
今腹ペコ状態なんで割といけると思いますタイガー
焼津すっ北大阪眺める得意じゃないんで卵稲荷3本ぐらいをよく食べるんです
美味しそうですねいただきます
[音楽]
うまい全然余裕でどんどん意気だぞ
10個目
でずっと食べてみた様々なんですけども4 us はい何が甘いので臓器の酢飯で食欲
がそそられてでもう僕は留まることを知りません
どうぞいきます
[音楽]
はい20皿食べてみて思った僕なんですけど強い勧めた食感が止ま20皿に近づくに
つれてなんかスポンジみたいななんていうのはちょっとたい方でスポンジを鴻上続けて
いる感じというかなんかこう
でしょうねつらいです頑張ります
me
ni
すごいなこれ we are 離散得るして
すごい産んでくれ
dee
ん
はいというわけで4頭打ちが全然46ってね
水5個4分の1を食べたところなんですけども結構
の限界ですよぐ
ani
[音楽]
me
水臭い室やはじめさ俺にもその稲荷食わせてくだせぇや
たまっつらっ
早く読んでくんないかなってやつや本当にすごいよ入ってるんですよね
ひとりだとちょっとランド所無事だったので2人で100個食べるように構っていき
たいとおもいます
後は任せた拉致 follow ためこっち食べるんですよね
ございます
すっ
のこういう集約予約いけそう
クソ涙目あ
ふーんモンドって何の真似だ
味に飽きるんですよ味に同じ単調な味が続くとそれでちょっと僕にもヤラれてるところ
はあるけどそういうなりなんなりを使って味変して見ていきます
野党だした
いやこれはキツイわねタブーなネットにくっつくないねこれなネットよりきついですよ
本当に
さすが japanese soul food になりー
おっ
ペットっ
やって貼ったやりいなかっだブラザーズつづく
わざとじゃねぇこんにゃろめてくる
the ずっと歌いました30個食べるって思った言葉
スポンジなんだよぽん酢食べる食べないでしょ
これ食べてるんであれば
土壌いっ
ん大谷ねー
んやっほぉやください本当にの言え a
[音楽]
興味やばい本当ずう3分えっちょっと終わってそっち行くから
あるって工場と言いますからどのようなんじゃないか気になるぜやべぇ
行っちまった
もう当たり引けねえ
終わったぁー
あっ
カムイてるんあ6でやばいって半分切っちゃって子供ちょっと入っています
いやマジで釣れこれこれ超辛いすわん
多いんだよ
ペペ
えっえっ心ですよえっ何がですね
ああああああ
でも交えもうすぐじゃないですけどすげー
ん
んあー
ブー
aname
tano
すごすぎれというわけで50分を食べました目標の100本には全然情報がないんで
こっからなるべくサーボとにもあります player ことは
ありません
[音楽]
最初はグーじゃんけんパーんっはいこれっしょ
あいこでしょ
勝負40本ここれはっはー
6本具どんどん
ban
部署ん
うんどーっ
oo
うん air
me
[音楽]
teame
car
me
あっはぁ